papapapa pam pam pam pam pam pam
j'en mange un double ou bulgare est je
danse la samba ap ap ap ap ap ap ap ap
ap à vous
ouais non je devais je vais essayer
autrement voilà comme ça je mange de
globules beauregard et jean casimir
tâche que singes à bonjour tu m'as l'air
bien dès aujourd'hui un gros nom je suis
en plein travail
françois et julie m'ont demandé de
chanter une nouvelle fois ma chanson
alors je cherche de nouveaux pas de
danse avant tu vas la chanter
aujourd'hui à 90 par insuline dans ma
nouvelle mise en scène n'est pas ton
portrait a tant mieux tant mieux parce
que moi aujourd'hui je n'ai pas le temps
j'ai une grande tournée comme je vais
absolument tu te vois
bon alors travaille bien on recase here
julie dites moi j'ai un colis pour
sabrina est ce que je peux vous le
donnez pas vieillir bon ben voila je
crois que c'est une cassette abbaoui ses
lacs ses mots qu'elle attendait pour son
catalogue sonore mais il n'y a pas eu à
trembler a non non non non il n'y a pas
de l'être non je n'ai rien vu bien dit
moi je vous laisse j'ai une grande
tournée au convoi si jean-françois que
j'ai tout ce qu'il faut et à samassa
voire réfractaires à sergio romero
tessa worley oui à tanger avec julie il
doit au fait j
est-ce que tu as reçu tous les bruits
mais oui je les ai reçus mais j'ai pas
la lettre de l qui doit comporter la
liste des noms à boom suis pas grave
cela au regard sur ma table j'ai tous
les objets à nous tous je crois qu'on va
trouver à quoi correspondait chacun de
ses six enfants
vous venez avec moi on y va aller on est
né avec moi au stade rennais venez on va
faire quelque chose on va faire un jeu
quasi mais il ya un jeu wii wii un jeu
qu'elle a ni rebond joue avec deux
projecteurs mis dans mon corps et quand
je prends facile pour moi alors écoutez
la règle du jeu
écouter la lecture julie a reçu des
sceaux pour son catalogue sonore et à
chacun de ces sons correspond à des
objets qui se trouvent là sur ma table
vous essaierez de me dire lequel vous
êtes d'accord t'as compris jury passera
un son un bruit vous écouterai bien et
vous me direz c'est le téléphone ou
c'est le moulin à café ou gravé et ses
deux mandats compris vous aussi vous
avez compris chez vous je joue avec nous
d'accord on y va et vient du lait au
christ et à la danse jusqu'à la
tristitude rencontre il a tout dit mais
non je n'ai pas donné de résultat julie
parce que le premier bruit cet appel
c'est le réveil c'est le réveil pourquoi
parce que je téléphone c'est un bruit
discontinues voilà vous aviez trouvé
bosser c'était le réveil bon et quand
bayrou venu du mois un petit peu ne
donnait pas tout de suite tout de suite
la réponse à 5 nos amis qui sont chez
eux et le temps aussi de jouer un
voulait c'est un petit peu le louis
s'écouler et après vous donner une
réponse
julie annonce il te plait vas-y envoyée
chercher
j'ai fait un numéro unique le moulin à
café carrosse et ça et vous comprenez si
vous parlez que le bruit ne sont pas
écoutés vous aviez trouvé c'était le
rasoir souffre et julie encore l'autre
oui
[Musique]
téléphone tu vas répondre c'est un
bosseur et bien oui c'était le téléphone
bon heureusement dijon si on avait
trouvé ça casse est meilleur qu'il
souffre de plaies écoute mais qu'est ce
que c'est joli coup à la bourse enel
[Musique]
c'est bien sage inégalée et oui c'est
fait la brosse à dents bon ben je crois
qu'on en a encore et c'est excellent et
concentrique et bien oui sophy c'était
les clés vous savez que ce fil rouge
tout j'espère que c'est pareil pour vous
encore le dernier
un joli inspirateur et je l'espère your
c'est le bruit d'aspirateur
quand on a monté le ménage ou pour la
respirateur c'était le dernier
bien dit moi casimir ouais j'espère que
tu es bien amusés pendant ce jeu les
coûts de françois le jeu j'ai rien
compris et aurillac mais alors
l'orchestré la musique était formidable